when investors or business people think
about how to deploy their capital and
how to deploy their time they always
think in terms of Roi very often people
uh make money uh through the discipline
of Roi they abandon that discipline when
it comes to giving it away and they
don't ask the same questions that enable
them to make efficient allocations of
capital and to achieve um significant
returns for the um money and time
invested welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
Mark Gerson thank you so much for uh
meeting me here 20 minute leaders I
really appreciate your time your energy
H thank you again for being here Michael
great to be with you wonderful huge fan
of your work uh definitely the impact
you've had on this world and then on so
many people and so many different
initiatives I think it's remarkable and
I'm looking forward to not only learning
about these initiatives and the impact
you've had but also the thesis behind
how you've made it so um without further
Ado let's just get into it Mark tell me
a little bit about yourself your journey
a little bit about where where you grew
up and where you came from how did you
even get to this concept of philanthropy
and and Roi impact driven yeah so um I
uh I grew up in Short Hills uh New
Jersey and uh then went to Williams
college graduated 94 then taught at
Inner City High School in Jersey City
before going to law school at Yale and
um I started uh Gerson lamber group GLG
during uh my third year at Yale and uh
um Thomas Lam and I launched it uh
really right as right when I graduated
in um May of 98 and uh and the uh
company did pretty well pretty quickly
we're very fortunate in that regard and
uh so I was able to begin my
philanthropic Journey um really in the
early
2000s and uh I would say the um when I
look back on it the uh the two really
important moments were um it was uh
probably in 2002 2003 when um an early
client of GLG uh said to me do you want
to meet um Ellie Beer uh yeah I I said
who's that he said um he's uh he's a a
medic from Israel and he's coming into
New York and I said I said to you're a
client of course I'll meet whoever you
want me to meet so I met Ellie um I
remember where where we were we had
dinner at uh wolf and lamb which uh
uh it was then I think it still is now
10 East 48 and uh and Ellie described to
me how people die all day every day
waiting for an ambulance and I said well
being in New York it makes a lot of
sense to me because I can easily imagine
um an ambulance said stuck in traffic uh
uh it's workers trying to get to whoever
called 911 and uh they're not being much
time for the victim to have a victim had
a heart attack or a stroke or is choking
or bleeding pursuant to accident or
something else there are usually very
often no more than 3 minutes that
separate life from death and Ellie's
point is that uh that person uh needs
help within those 3 minutes sometimes 90
seconds um and it takes an ambulance 10
minutes in the best of cases whether in
New York or Tel Aviv or even the most
advanced cities like those um it takes
an ambulance 10 minutes because they get
stuck in traffic they're never right
nearby or rarely right nearby but
Ellie's Insight was that um you don't
need an ambulance immediately his
Insight was that an ambulance is a
fundamentally a transport vehicle and
what the victim needs immediately is a
trained and equipped first responder at
his or her side who can uh save the life
of the victim and uh and the victim
needs that trained and equipped first
responder there within 90 seconds or a
little more hopefully 90 seconds and the
ambulance can come 10 minutes later and
the ambulance workers can then relieve
the uh the volunteer medic who's been
there for 8 minutes or so and uh
transport the patient to the hospital as
needed and uh we started the um the
organization uh shortly thereafter which
uh became uh United Holo of Israel that
that's incredible and so this is not the
only philanthropic organization that
you're a part of that makes a tremendous
impact you're also a part of African
Mission Healthcare amongst others tell
me a little bit about these other
initiatives and the different impact
you're making there and then I want to
tie back together into your greater
vision and thesis on how to make a how
to make strong impact yeah terrific so
um yeah African Mission Healthcare so
the jet we started in 200 10 but the
Genesis of it was um oh about 10 years
earlier than that which is when um my
close friend from college John Fielder
graduated uh well he graduated um
Medical School Bor then he went to The
Residency program at John's Hopkins
Medical School and he called me upon
Leading The Residency program and he
said um he said as you know I'm a
Christian and uh and he feel he said
therefore I feel called to by my faith
to go serve the um people who were then
being ravaged by uh HIV uh in Africa and
so he uh he told me what a medical
missionary a Christian Missionary
physician was and he said that's what
that's who I am and uh so he went to um
Kenya in um 20012 2002 when HIV and AIDS
were really ravaging Africa and uh and
he uh he began uh treating HIV and AIDS
patients in the most difficult
conditions imaginable um before uh there
was anything approaching the
distribution of Therapeutics which have
by now made HIV a manageable chronic
disease rather than a sure killer and so
Jang was there early on and uh um and he
was treating patients before pepar pepar
is the president's emergency plan for
AIDS relief which was President Bush's
plan announced in 2003 which has been um
almost certainly the greatest American
humanitarian uh intervention since the
Marshall Plan it saved uh tens of
millions of of people in Africa from
sure death from HIV um which was a
humanitarian uh victory of extraordinary
proportions um and uh simultaneously um
it prevented what would have been failed
States throughout Africa because HIV
would have taken down governments and um
and it made uh many of the countries in
Africa which um were the main
beneficiaries of the pepar program are
now some of the most pro-american
countries in the world so it was a huge
success all along so Jong was um one of
the one of the doctors on the ground
implementing it and uh he was traveling
throughout Africa working with um uh HIV
and AIDS patients and said uh you know
the biggest humanitarian problem in the
world gives a lack of access to care for
almost everybody in Africa whereas um
most African countries had one doctor
for every 30 to 50,000 people which
meant that whether you had HIV a
pregnancy complication your daughter
broke her leg whatever it is uh you
weren't going to get any treatment or
certainly any decent treatment and he
said um that's wrong it's unne and it's
unnecessary because there are people who
are there and more they can come who are
willing and able to do this work and
these are Christian Missionary doctors
serving at Christian hospitals
throughout Africa but they've
effectively been abandoned in the field
um for a variety of reasons mainly
because um they used to be supported
significantly by the denominations um
but the denominations progressively got
poorer and weaker as non-denominational
Evangelical churches started to pick up
and and a lot of these missionaries just
got abandoned effectively abandoned so
we set up African Mission Healthcare in
200 10 to partner with uh Christian
Missionary doctors at Christian
hospitals to provide clinical care for
the poor to build infrastructure and to
do training and now we work in 15 16 or
so different countries doing um lots of
surgery which is surgery and Maternal
Child Care the one in two or two in one
top two problems in um Healthcare in
Africa that's where we work the most and
uh we work um in direct clinical care we
also uh build infrastructure such as
oxygen such as consistent power such as
housing we work very closely with our
Christian Hospital Partners to identify
what they specifically need that will
enable them to deploy money most
efficiently and serve patients now and
in the near future and uh so we do this
in a variety of countries and
uh and uh for basically um collectively
every kind of condition that's it that's
incredible to tie it all together you're
also passionate about history you're
you're writing books on history you're
connecting
you're to really you know holistic thing
there what is it about history that
really excites you how does this all tie
into your greater vision for your impact
and the things that you really care
about and you're devoting your time to
well my my last book was um came out in
2021 um uh peso which was of course the
spring and uh peso's a quintessential
spring holiday and uh it was on how the
um meeting of life is revealed in mahag
and mahag is of course the guide that we
Jews uh use uh to get us through the
guide us through the Passover seder
which is the most important and best uh
religious ritual there is the Passover
seder uh it's the Jewish Spring Festival
and the haad is a book we used to guide
us through it the hagad is basically the
greatest hits of the Torah and uh so the
book uh goes through the sections of the
hagad which are familiar to every Jew
and increasingly familiar to the
Gentiles who host their own saders or
attend our saders and uh go through and
talk about how the Jew Jewish notion of
the good meaningful fulfilling life um
is revealed in the hagada and passages
that um may not seem profound but they
all are all right so diving into Roi and
in the context of impact on philanthropy
Roi is an investor as an entrepreneur
pretty clear how I measure it in the in
you know in the traditional uh Tech
space and in business in business what
does it mean for
you uh yeah it's a very good question so
cuz you're exactly right when when when
investors or business people think about
how to deploy their capital and how to
deploy their time they always think in
terms of Roi the only question is
whether they do it intentionally or
intuitively but they always and only
think in terms of Roi the only question
that they ask fundamentally is how much
money am I do I expect to get in the
future for the dollars I'm investing now
or how much value am I going to create
for the time I'm committing now and it's
all a function of Roi what's my return
on investment whether whether it's time
or it's money every business person asks
this question really all the time um and
when it comes to deploying philanthropic
Capital uh the same people very often
don't ask the question and they don't
and certainly don't rigorously try to
analyze what's my return now the return
will be measured should be measured in
one of three things how how many lives
will I saved how much paying will I
humiliate or how much opportunity will I
create those are the three things you
can do with philanthropy per dollar
invested and uh and all too often uh
people who create wealth or and by
wealth we can very broadly Define that
because um uh a good charitable
organization can make a tremendous
amount of use over a a small amount of
dollars so uh there's really no such
thing as a a small charitable gift to
the right organization but uh but when
when but very often people uh um make
money uh through the discipline of Roi
they abandon that discipline when it
comes to giving it away and they don't
ask the same questions that enable them
to make efficient allocations of capital
and to achieve um significant returns
for the um money and time invested and
so when uh my wife who's a rabbi when
she and I give uh philanthropically we
always and only think in terms of return
investment we always want to know with
mathematical Precision uh how much what
is the outcome as measured by as I said
um Live Safe pain amili rated
opportunities created what is going to
be the outcome mathematically per dollar
invested and um any decent charitable
organization and any decent
philanthropic Endeavor lends itself to
precisely that question and uh and uh it
may and by viewing philanthropy and by
doing philanthropy through the lens of
Roi it means that one who gives whether
one's giving $18 a month or tens of
millions a year um can have a a very
significant impact um in the area where
one is uh is drawn to
participate and so if we're looking at
the landscape today of and first of all
I think it's fascinating and and I
absolutely love it how do you how do you
see the landscape today of not only
philanthropy but also those that are
running these Charities and running
these nonprofit organizations how how
meticulous are they and how rigorous are
they in this form of thinking of Roi and
and where are we at with our ecosystem
because obviously you know these are so
you know we these are incredible um you
know incredible organizations that
you're a part of and I'm curious as to
how you're observing the greater
landscape here yeah I mean it's well I
mean I it's a really good question
because I think that people who run when
we say who runs a Char organization that
that could Define someone who chairs the
board to the executive director who
operates on a daily basis both of them
should think in terms of Roi and if a
chable if if the leaders of a chatable
organization can articulate their Roi
they might they just might not have an
Roi which should be a particular
interest to a potential uh contributor I
mean just take a look at United Huts all
so United Huts all let's let's take a
look at the world pre- October 7th okay
because that's where I have the the data
I mean I have the data post October 7th
but the following data comes pre October
7th pre- October 7th we were doing 1900
calls a day this is throughout Israel
and our Volunteers Of course are are uh
hered Jews secular Jews Arab Christians
Arab Muslims men women everybody
collectively GRS everybody they're doing
1900 calls a day um according to studies
of 911 systems in the US which would be
exactly the same as in Israel cuz the
call distribution is precisely the same
people have heart attacks and strokes
and choking and bleeding everywhere
there's absolutely accidents there's
absolutely no difference um 6.9% of
calls to 911 in Israel we're 1221 but
911 again the same thing are 6.9% are
potential life saving
interventions so let's say that we're
able to um save approximately half of
those some people would not have died
some people die anyway but let's say by
getting there within the 3 minutes to
separate life from Death by getting to
the accident victim who's Bleeding Out
by getting to the choke a victim who's
about to suffocate uh by getting to the
heart attack victim uh before his
heart's about to give away we're able to
save a lot of lives so we're able so
let's say we were able to save half of
the potential life-saving interventions
and then let's say that we put a um 15
we've put a 15% values we said that
every non-p potential life saving call
is worth 15% of a potential life saving
call because it can't be worth nothing I
mean if we're helping a pregnant women
um a pregnant woman give birth in a
vulnerable moment in her apartment um it
may not be saving a life but it's really
valuable so you have to Value it at
something so you take all the the lives
saved plus you put everything else at
15% of a life saved and then you take
our annual budget which is around 54 55
million a year and it comes out to about
$500 per life-saving equivalent so
that's our Roi you put a dollar in you
put $500 in you basically have the
equivalent of saving a life unbelievable
yeah and and the that similar kind of
math should lend itself to everything I
mean at our work in in Africa we know
that um that if only about 20% of women
um who need a C-section will get one so
a lot of what we do is build maternal uh
child uh Health capacity so for instance
at the at our clinic in Uganda which is
um one of the main areas where we do
Maternal Child Child Care uh we know
that for about
$350 um we can enable a woman who needs
needs a C-section to get it while
training other providers to learn how to
do C-sections so that the discipline of
Performing C-sections can be expanded
throughout Africa so if a woman needs a
C-section and doesn't get it one of
three things will happen she's going to
die which is why 138 women in Africa die
on child birth she's going to get a
fisal or she's going to get a birth
injury and these birth injuries um will
last until she can get surgery and
because there are so few surgeons around
that when she can get surgery maybe
never or maybe decades and in the intrum
she's going to be urinating and
defecating through her vagina and
persistently leaking so Michael you and
I can't even imagine how degrading that
kind of life is um but what we can
imagine what we can do is know that for
$350 we can save that woman's life um or
if she was going to live anyway uh
prevent her from living that kind of
degrading life so what's the ROI on that
well in Maternal Child Care you have
double the ROI right because you have
the the mother mother and the
baby but you actually have more than
that because if a mother has a birth
injury or a fistula she really can't be
the kind of mother that she would be to
her other children she's often
physically ostracized and certainly
can't be the kind of mother she would be
as if she weren't leaking all the time
so you're able to save a mother and her
child and to significantly enhance the
lives of her other children who now have
a mother when they otherwise really
wouldn't all for a few hundred so the
ROI of that is spectacular and you know
the similar kind of math can be applied
to uh surgery can be applied to HIV care
HIV care and surgery about the same Roi
I mean both um both I mean just to give
an example the uh partner we work with
Dr Tom CA and I anyone who's interested
can should just look up the profile that
Nick Kristoff of the New York Times
wrote on Tom CA in 2015 it's on the New
York Times website of course but uh Tom
serves in the nuba mountains and um
we're his main partner there and and uh
so Tom's the only surgeon serving a
population of now 2 million people so uh
the budget of Tom's Hospital excluding
the food last year was about $1.6
million and uh for that Tom and his
colleagues were able to do about 180,000
outpatients 7,000 impatients 2600
surgeries 550 difficult births plus
malaria TB and leprosy and training for
a million and a half so what's the ROI
on that spectacular so when we think
about how we give I think everyone
should just think about what's the ROI
what's my return of investment if I put
a dollar in What's My outcome out and
when one starts to think that way and
it's it's it's a very customary way of
thinking because everyone who has an
online brokerage account thinks about it
that way think when it comes to
investment Capital so just think about
the same thing when it comes to
philanthropic Capital it's money either
way so it's just uh what's my
quantitatively measured outcomes out per
dollar in so I think when people think
in terms of Roi in their giving they'll
both make much better decisions and
they'll avoid really bad decisions and
ultimately having a much greater impact
altogether absolutely and that's the
whole point of it exactly ex I mean
people talk about impact investing with
regards to philanthropy or they should
right how do you measure it like it's
it's just otherwise it's just a word and
and if it's just a word it's just virtue
signaling like how do you like I'm we're
we're all for impact investing when it
comes to philanthropy when it comes to
philanthropy I think Financial investing
and philanthropy should be separate
things
and someone should try to make as much
money as he can and then give as much
money away as he can as intelligently
and effectively and efficiently as one
can but when it comes to giving it away
of course one should optimize and
maximize the impact people say that and
that's great but that's just the
beginning but then how do you measure
your impact and uh and people are are um
are gravitate to all kinds of charitable
Endeavors for all kinds of reasons and
that's great because everyone can't do
one thing like the highest impact things
we do in the world is probably providing
surgery in Africa just okay but but
people are going to be drawn to all
kinds of different things and uh and
that's fine but whatever someone is
drawn to I think the first question you
have to say like is this the kind of
thing that lend itself to Roi and if the
answer is the Opera or the ballet the
answer is it does it doesn't lend itself
to Roi it's not a charity it's a
consumption good where you're lucky to
get a tax reduction but don't think of
it as Charity because it's not many
universities ballets operas Symphonies
that whole category of things uh it's
with with some exceptions like obviously
a university medical school that does
certain research in a certain area
that's different but by by and large
these things they don't lend themselves
to um to Roi in some cases that negative
Roi so but if one gravitates to a c to a
certain cause perhaps because of a
personal experience perhaps because of
something they observed wonderful but
approach the cause with a lens to Roi
and uh and what whatever and the the ROI
in giving can be spectacular really one
of my mentors in in philanthropy is John
Curley who lives in Tampa and John is a
real Champion um both um as as a leader
and also as a philanthropist he's given
away a ton of money himself um and a a
ton of the percentage of his wealth he
makes money and then gives it away to um
enable poor children in um Inner City
Florida to get um uh effectively School
vouchers educational opportunity
opportunity scholarships and John has
transformed the lives of hundreds of
thousands of kids um and the ROI is so
measurable I mean if if you you you
invest X thousands of dollars into
helping a child attend the school that's
right for him and uh you he can measure
um by test scores by college um by whe
by whether they go to college by where
they go to college by a whole variety of
other metrics um the life Improvement uh
based upon the education that he's
investing in again great
Ro mark thank you so much this was just
wonderful inspiring I'm so excited to
share this and for myself as well thank
you for all the amazing work that you're
doing and for Tak this time share with
me thank you for the opportunity to
share
[Music]
Michael